[Music]
in Surah 29 verse 46 the Quran commands
Muslims to say to Christians we believe
in what has been revealed to us and in
what has been revealed to you Our God
and your God is one and to him we submit
yet many Muslims say something very
different to Christians they say we
don't believe in your book because it's
been corrupted and your God is a false
god
[Music]
if Muslims are commanded to say that
they believe in what has been revealed
to us
why do they instead say that they don't
believe in the Bible the only revelation
we have
and if they're commanded to say that our
God and their God is one
what do they instead say that our God is
a false god
[Music]
according to the Bible God is a trinity
one in nature or Essence but three in
person Father Son and Holy Spirit
the son entered creation as Jesus of
Nazareth Jesus died on the cross for
sins and rose from the dead
the Quran denies all of this so a Muslim
can't say that he believes in the Bible
or that Allah and the god of the Bible
are the same God
Muslims have to reject the Bible because
the Bible contradicts the Quran
[Music]
but Muslims have a problem here
the Quran declares that the Torah and
the gospel were revealed by Allah
Surah 3 verses 3 through 4.
he has revealed to you the book with
truth
verifying that which is before it
and he revealed the Torah and the gospel
of four time a guidance for the people
and he sent the Quran
so Allah revealed the Torah and the
gospel as a guidance
but our Muslim friends tell us that
Allah couldn't protect the Torah in the
gospel and that both Revelations were
corrupted by men
what Allah sent to guide people ended up
misguiding people convincing Christians
that God is a trinity and that Jesus
died on the cross for sins
of course we should be puzzled when
Muslims tell us that the Torah and the
gospel were changed because the Quran
states that no one can change Allah's
words
Surah 18 verse 27.
and recite what has been revealed to you
of the book of your lord
there is none who can change his words
and you shall not find any Refuge
besides him
[Music]
here our Muslim friends might say this
verse only means that no one can change
the Quran
[Music]
but the verse doesn't say that no one
can change the Quran
says that no one can change Allah's
words
and the Torah and The Gospel According
to the Quran
are Allah's words
despite Allah's clear declaration that
no one can change his words many Muslims
assert that the gospel was corrupted by
the Apostle Paul or by later Christians
if the gospel is corrupted
we can only wonder why the Quran says
that Christians still had the gospel
during the time of Muhammad
Surah 7 verse 157
[Music]
those who follow the messenger the
unlettered prophet whom they find
mentioned in their own scriptures in the
Torah and the gospel
it is they who will prosper
[Music]
and Christians find Muhammad mentioned
in the gospel when the gospel was
supposedly corrupted centuries earlier
is Allah saying that we find Muhammad
mentioned in our corrupted scriptures
but we don't find Muhammad mentioned in
our scriptures at all
except as part of a general warning
about false prophets who come to lead
people away from the gospel
and if we did find Muhammad mentioned in
our scriptures how would we know that
this wasn't one of the corrupted parts
and since our scriptures contradict
Islam
why would Allah appeal to them as
evidence for Islam
but Allah goes much further than this He
commands Christians to judge by the
gospel
Surah 5 verse 47.
let the people of the Gospel judge by
what Allah hath revealed therein
if any do fail to judge by the light of
what Allah hath revealed
they are no better than those who Rebel
why does Allah command us to judge by a
corrupt book
the only gospel we have contradicts
Islam so in order to obey Allah's
command we would have to judge by the
gospel and conclude that Islam is false
a law continues along these same lines
in Surah 5 68.
say o people of the book you have no
ground to stand upon unless you stand
fast by the Torah the gospel and all the
Revelation that has come to you from
your lord
[Music]
why would Allah tell us that we have no
ground to stand upon unless we stand
upon a corrupt book
if the gospel has been corrupted
wouldn't Allah just tell us to get rid
of it and believe in the Quran
so the Quran clearly maintains that the
gospel is authoritative for Christians
and this only makes sense if the author
of the Quran believed that Christians
have the word of God
but the gospel wasn't just authoritative
for Christians it was also authoritative
from Muhammad himself and therefore
Muslims
one day Muhammad started having doubts
about his Revelations
in response to these doubts Salah
commanded Muhammad to go to the people
of the book Jews and Christians for
confirmation
Surah 10 verse 94.
but if you o Muhammad
are in doubt as to what we have revealed
to you
ask those who read the book before you
certainly the truth has come to you from
your lord therefore you should not be of
the disputers
Muslims today act as if the Quran stands
in judgment over the Bible
since the Bible contradicts the Quran
Muslims assume that the Bible must be
rejected
but in the Quran it's exactly the
opposite
the Bible stands in judgment over the
Quran and Muhammad himself could only
confirm his Revelations by checking to
see if they line up with the scriptures
of the people of the book
since Muhammad continued preaching Islam
he apparently never took this test very
seriously
if he had gone to the people of the book
in search of confirmation he would have
been forced to reject the Quran
because the Quran puts Muslims in an
inescapable dilemma
either Christians have the inspired
preserved authoritative word of God or
we don't
those are the only two possibilities
if we have the inspired preserved
authoritative word of God Islam is false
because Islam contradicts what we have
if we don't have the inspired preserved
authoritative word of God
Islam is false because the Quran affirms
the inspiration preservation and
authority of our book
so if the gospel is the word of God
Islam is false if the gospel isn't the
word of God Islam is false
either way Islam is false
by affirming scriptures that contradict
its core teachings Islam self-destructs
Muslims who don't want to believe in a
religion that self-destructs will
therefore need to find a new religion
let's encourage our Muslim friends to
obey the gospel
as both of our religions command
[Music]